julio tehran this will be his first
start on the year
recently an angel has spent his career
seven year major league career with the
braves off speed bouncer to the right
side fletcher has to come in on it good
pitching that'll do it they had a threat
although no hits in the inning they do
leave a runner at third base he's not
looking like a guy's uh is being timid
or he's giving it everything
okay ryan you like that though you had
to get this right upstairs with some
cheese and white chases the slider
that's that wicked slider he'd get a
swing of his wife
max stassi with one away and he actually
has a five-game hitting streak coming in
kind of a quiet little hitting streak
and that is drilled out toward left
center field kyle lewis going to watch
this one go big fly for max stassie
one-nothing angels max continues to
entertain this with the long ball this
year
three home runs for max dassey that
baseball everyone knew was long gone off
the bat
425 foot home run well two two picks
trout coming in coming in
not going to get a base hit it's going
to make this catch many times it's not
quite able to get there one out base
runner here in the third
broken bat papa
another long run for trout he's coming
on hard he won't get that with a couple
of bloops
we get a blast to follow we really get a
formula here left on left mariners a
chance here to tie if not take the lead
high drive right field that baby's gone
or do that
that thing is long gone a three-run
check by kyle sieger the mariners have a
3-1 lead
continues to drive in runs career blast
number 200 for kyle
big time
marco's giving up one hit the staffing
home run third inning 0-2
pitch like i said staying right with it
there's a strike at his fourth marco
gonzalez
pitching a beauty so far through four
strike three called five k's for marco
that's his second looking to that hit
the big horse ride
strikeout number six
for marco gonzalez he has been
outstanding tonight again against the
halo the lead off double here's kyle
lewis the 1-0 pitch the cow swinging a
ground ball skips off the top of the
mountain into center field for a base
hit more ronnie third being waved in by
maniaca dillon will score easily up with
the ball as trout the throw will go into
second base
kyle lewis with an rbi single to center
scoring dylan moore it's now the
mariners four and the angels won and for
kyle lewis rbi number 10 on the year
pokemon 3-2 lifted in the air
down the line long run for rendon he was
in the shift and did he make the play he
did what a play by anthony rendon to the
backhand
that is a tough play and smooth as
always with a smile on his face
covered a ton of ground david fletcher
for two with a ground out in the flap on
the left oh two now
that is out toward left field dylan
moore giving chase toward the corner
gone big fly for david fletcher his
second in his many nights
it's 4-2 seattle
this doesn't panic when he falls behind
in the count so good with
two strikes on him makes adjustment hand
is so quick he's always making contact
second home run of the season back to
back nice fletch so here's mike trout
batting
oh
man that's got some sound
lewis back to the wall
did he get it no
big fly for mike trout
the angels with back-to-back jacks
and now they're down one trout
back-to-back games papa trout
going yard after fletch goes yard
runners at the corners now here's nola
one for three with the double breaking
ball
right center field long run adele long
run trout nobody got it it's banging
around out there nola will hold with a
two-run double and america's lead at 6-3
well two rbis last night how about a
couple more tonight
service moving him up in the lineup
hitting him fifth tonight and it paid
off got evan white here a couple of men
aboard
it well it's going to stay fair adele
can't get it
nola scores it bounces over the fence of
being an automatic devil in rbi for evan
white good to see the young man come
through after three strikeouts tonight
the mariners have a 7-3 lead travel step
up two out to two on 3-2 all the way to
trout that is hammered
out to left field no doubter
big fly for mike trout his second of the
ball game the angels are down one and
another home run versus a slider and
another home run versus seattle papa
trout some dad power
edwards has plenty of experience he's
gonna need to call on it here struck him
out that's the ball game and the
mariners win it's 7-6